that they could then use to compete with
your kids to buy property and I think
when you think about the tax system
I think another story that illustrates
it quite well is you know I've Got
Friends
um you know I think of one friend who's
you know very well educated and he earns
probably about three times average
income now and
he lives with his mom to try and save up
money to buy a house and because he's
earning higher than average income he
probably pays you know
above 50 percent
if you include National Insurance on his
on his income
um
and when he goes to buy properties those
properties are not getting bought by
people who got given half a million
pound tax-free from their mom
um
I think this kind of highlights what's
happening you know my friend is paying
50 because he's from a poor family and
that personally buys that house is
paying zero percent on their income
because they're from a better off family
and The Duke of Westminster inherits 9
billion pound and and
pays nothing because he's from a very
very rich family